Hollywood rights America out of the
moon-landing nike turns colin kaepernick
into real life
Al Bundy and lefty has learned the most
important business lesson of the Trump
era get woke go broke then Steve Bannon
is disinvited from The New Yorker
conference Oh No Democrats scraped the
bottom of the barrel for 2020
politicians politicized John McCain's
funeral and I explained Sarah
Silverman's own joke to her I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
you've probably noticed something really
horrible I was so excited to get here
today there is so much to talk about
that I forgot my Rachel Maddow glasses I
can't find them I don't know where they
are this obviously is the source of my
power I can now no longer read Donald
Trump's tax returns and find out that he
really paid taxes
I can't spread fake news quite as easily
as I once did so I don't know we're
gonna be flying by the seat of our pants
today but hopefully they turn up and I
get all of my powers back before we get
to a lot of news because we got a lot to
talk about and the left is learning a
wonderful lesson get woke go broke
filling up my tumbler by the second
before we get to that I want to thank a
sponsor mint mobile Oh is mint good hey
do you have one of these things do you
have a wife I have one of these people
yell at me and they say that I you know
because I don't answer my phone mint is
now my makes cell phone so much easier
and more affordable to use because you
know what happens you go to the big cell
phone company you sign up for their plan
and they charge you a zillion dollars a
month for unlimited data and the bill is
always twice as much as you signed up to
pay mint has has figured this out be the
big in big wireless stands for big
contracts big bills big secrets mint
Mobile is the game-changing company
that's taken everything wrong with big
Wireless and made it right it's proving
to millions of Americans that your
wireless bill doesn't have to be the
worst day of your month it will cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month they have plans ranging from 15
bucks you can go a little bit higher if
you want more data but when I say 15
bucks a month I mean 15 bucks a month I
don't mean 15 bucks a month plus $300 in
fees and taxes and whatever I mean 15
bucks a month you can keep your old
number all of your existing contacts you
can choose to five or ten gigabyte 4G
LTE plans the way that those big
companies get you is they sell you a ton
of data that you don't need don't do
that go with mint if you're not a
hundred percent satisfied they give you
a seven day money back guarantee outfox
the old wireless bill start saving with
mint mobile 15 bucks a month plus free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card go
to mint mobile.com / co f f/a co v fe fe
mint mobile comm / co f f/a co v fe fe
get it down to 15 bucks a month get a
free shipping on your mint Mobile SIM
card mint mobile comm / cough FA Co V Fe
Fe okay let's get into this today
now that we've got the cellphone squared
away we've were mourning the loss of my
rachel maddow glasses
let's mourn the loss of leftist
companies money because they are
learning this hard lesson repeat after
me
get woke go baroque the first guy that's
learning about this is is the CEO of
Nike right now because you might have
heard Ryan Gosling angered half of the
country over the weekend by writing the
American flag out of the moon landing
and defending that decision so I I think
he thought that he had the best way to
offend Americans over the weekend and
then Nike turned to him and said Ryan
hold my gatorade because they decided to
make the new face of Nike the new image
that they are gonna put on all of their
advertising Colin Kaepernick the guy who
who disrespects and protests the
American flag the symbol of the country
itself the the quote that they're using
on this stupid image of Kaepernick said
says believe in something even if it
means sacrificing everything here's how
people are reacting
I'm enjoy hell I might buy go buy some
adidas hmm you know how many other
sneakers are to buy to choose from there
to go ahead you're gonna go ahead and
say hey buy them our shoes we stand with
people who kneel for the national anthem
well sorry Nike I've been buying you for
the past twenty plus years
not anymore for those of you who are
just listening I think you got the gist
of it you could probably hear the little
sweatshop produced shoes crackling in
the background but this guy's burning is
set of sneakers and this is really hard
for me because I don't know that I've
ever even considered wearing running
shoes out in public I don't I'm not a
big exercise guy as you might have
discovered but let me tell you something
if Nike produced penny loafers they
would have lost one customer today baby
they would be out of it they don't they
don't make that unfortunately but I
still
now anytime I do buy athletic you're not
using Nike I think this is true of half
the country
this statement is obviously ridiculous
this believe in something even if it
means sacrificing everything
conservatives get this wrong sometimes
because we to focus on the form and not
just the and not the content so you can
believe in
I mean it now believed in something
Stalin believed in something Hitler
believed in something all of the worst
ideologues in history have believed in
something they've just believed in bad
things David Duke believes in something
right doesn't Louis Farrakhan believes
it do you believe in something but the
question is what are you believing in
and what Colin Kaepernick believes in is
that he hates the United States he hates
this country I I want to spell this out
I've been tweeting about this and and
the left doesn't seem to understand this
Colin Kaepernick is protesting the
United States itself the country itself
how do I deduce this well Colin
Kaepernick is protesting the national
anthem which is the star-spangled banner
which is the American flag which is a
symbol of the country itself the flag
represents the country the star-spangled
banner represents the country now people
will say well he doesn't say he's he's
protesting the flag that's not true by
the way he does say that he's protesting
the flag he said I will not stand up for
a flag of a country that oppresses black
people or whatever whatever he changed
is your is so he actually does say to
these protesting the flag but even if he
didn't even if he said even if he stands
there he's kneeling he's he's not gonna
stand up for the American flag and he
says I'm really protesting mint
chocolate chip ice cream
no you don't understand I'm protesting
mint chocolate chip ice cream you said
no but no you're not you might be saying
that you might think that that's what
you're protesting but you're not because
what you are protesting in a
demonstrable way in a verifiable way I
can look at the video you are protesting
the star-spangled banner which is the
flag which represents the country that's
what he's doing and this guy I don't
think we should defend this guy at all
because some of the conservatives get
this wrong true they'll say well I
defend I defend his right to protest say
sure like sure I don't know that anybody
does
agrees with that and they'll say the
flag stands in part for the right to
protest and therefore I support his
protest know that yeah you're actually
right the flag does in part stand for
the right to protest that's why it's so
idiotic to protest it because it's a
self-defeating protest your approach
that is true if the flag stands in part
for the right to protest then you're
protesting the right to protest so what
are you left with you're undercutting
your own demonstration the chest
gestures and said there's a thought that
stops thought that's the only thought
that ought to be stopped but beyond this
for the people who think that Colin
Kaepernick is really just this
high-minded racial justice activist
who's really seeing something that we're
not all seeing it beyond the statistics
he's really seeing a de jure or de facto
policy of discrimination against black
people by the police department if
that's really what's happening first of
all why isn't he protesting police
departments why is he protesting the
flag but also why does he make all of
his other statements why does he wear
t-shirts of Fidel Castro why does he
make openly anti-american statements the
the the left is trying to turn this guy
into as some civil rights hero that's
not what he is he's what the communists
would call a useful idiot here's Colin
Kaepernick defending Fidel Castro so
it's good to have an open mind about
Fidel Castro and his oppression I'm not
talking about the Bell Castro and I'm
talking about literacy rate because they
invest more in their education system
than they do in our prisons or public we
do not do here he also did something
that we do not do here he broke up
families he took over a country again
without any you know
justice and without any elections we do
break up families here that's what mass
incarceration is that was the foundation
of slavery so our country has been based
on that as well as identified Native
American are you equated the breaking up
of Cuban families with people going to
jail in the United States of America
i'ma craving the breaking up of family
who's breaking up with them Wow amazing
that is amazing that is really amazing
because this guy's a dolt I mean I'm not
saying that he's the main issue here but
he's a dolt who is being used by
seriously bad people and defending
seriously bad things like Fidel Castro
none of what he said is true by the way
that I've been to Cuba
I don't think Colin Kapernick has been
to Cuba I've been to Cuba I've talked to
the Cuban people the the propaganda that
comes out of the Castro slave regime is
that they have the greatest education
system they have the greatest health
care system it isn't true I was talking
to a Cuban he said there's the there's
the hospital there's the famous hospital
in Havana said oh so anybody can go in
there and it's universal health care
said yeah anybody can go in there there
won't be any medicine you can't get any
surgery done but you can go in yeah
everybody can go in and when you do go
and you've got to bring your own toilet
paper you've got to bring your own tools
you've got to bring your own instruments
and really what happens is people just
purchase healthcare on the black market
there it's it's slavery says the the
Castro's don't break up families they're
not though that we weep by imprisoning
our criminals we're a slave country
Fidel Castro imprisoned a whole nation a
whole country for decade upon decade
this is the kind of stuff Colin
Kaepernick stands up for this has
nothing to do with police brutality in
the United States that says everything
to do with his is actually communist
idiocy is actual defense demonstrable
verifiable there it is I'm not creating
something out of thin air defending
communist thugs this is an anti-american
ideology and it's an anti-american
ideology that fuels that protest before
we get any further I cuz I've got to
check the time so that we don't run out
of time today let me thank movement you
know movement in VMT we don't got time
for Val
movement is that company founded by
those two college dropouts they started
a watch company it's growing like crazy
they've sold almost 2 million watches in
over 160 countries around the world they
are revolutionising fashion on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank
I loved watches I've learnt to watch
since I was 8 years old I've always gone
shopping for really good watches I've
always wanted to get a decent deal too
and sometimes if you if you went into a
department store you got this movement
watch this one is from the revolver
collection which is their coolest
collection this would cost four or five
hundred dollars movement cuts out the
middleman I will tell you every time I
go to specifically to the bank but I've
noticed this at other places too but
literally every single time I go to the
bank people compliment me on this watch
other places I go to the parties at bars
I get compliments on this watch all the
time it looks really really cool I love
their stuff you've got to go out and buy
it so that they send me more freebies
because I've actually bought these
watches myself they are so good and the
way I do that is with the promo code
cuff fa get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to MB
MT comm slash cough FAC o VF e EF e CY
movement keeps growing CY I keep buying
it for my family and friends it is great
and they've got an expanding collection
MVM t.com / co f fa co the fe fe joy and
the movement so that's that's colin
kaepernick the issue here though isn't
just colin kaepernick
because some some guy you know some guy
who is at the end of his football career
and now has to become a shoe salesman
that's the real life story of al bundy
as many people and the internet we're
pointing out this is also terrible
business so i woke up this morning this
was trending all day yesterday nike
hashtag just do it hashtag boycott Nike
said this isn't good I've noticed that
when when the left when the left takes
over businesses those businesses go down
their profit margins shrink and they
start to lose money this is exactly what
happened by the time I woke up this
morning Nike was down four billion
dollars in market capitalization this is
all because of Colin Kaepernick and it's
been fluctuating all day between three
and four billion dollars they're down
this is not just a regular fluctuation
in their trading this is a direct
response to Kaepernick and it is a
significant drop of the 3% in the value
of their company this is true across
businesses they I don't I really don't
understand why the left
keeps doubling down on this or rather
why businesses keep doubling down on the
left it is costing the money left and
right and this tells us something about
our politics you're gonna hear Democrats
and critics of the administration
harping on the generic ballot
oh no the generic ballot looks really
bad for the midterm so no the generic
ballot looks really bad for 2020 the
numbers that we're seeing coming out of
Nike the numbers that we're seeing
coming out of other businesses who
embrace the left are telling us a lot
more than the generic opinion polls from
political analysts are telling us a lot
more and well we can see it with this
Ryan Gosling movie the first man
directed by Damien Chazelle is that how
you pronounce his name
Damien chase all I don't know he's the
guy who did lala land and now they've
done this movie called the first man
which is about the moon landing and in
the moment where Neil Armstrong touches
down they cut out the planting of the
American flag in the moon
Ryan Gosling gave his explanation of
this he said quote I think this was
widely regarded in the end as a human
achievement and that's how we chose to
view it I also think Neil was extremely
humble as were many of these astronauts
and time and time again he deferred the
focus from himself to the 400,000 people
who made the mission possible so Ryan
Gosling you're speaking for Neil
Armstrong who most certainly would have
called himself an American and was a
proud American Buzz Aldrin is ripping
this movie for not showing the American
flag ripping this political talking
point but it's I think I've actually
explode out why Ryan Gosling is spouting
the sort of stupidity this was in a
little watched aspect of a Jimmy Kimmel
interview that's why nobody watched it
obviously because it was part of a Jimmy
Kimmel interview but here Ryan Gosling
explains the only plausible explanation
for his defense of not including the
flag but it's this thing that kind of
sends you like you know ass over
teakettle for like you know like they
would only do it for maybe 20 minutes at
a time or something but in the movie
because we had to get a lot of shots I
was in it for like six to eight hours
for real got with it going yeah so I
started to just sort of smell a rat up
here you know what do you mean well like
that I was something was wrong like I
was I was that and getting banged or
in the capsules and hitting my head that
something might be wrong what was wrong
well I knew something was wrong when I
called I went home one night and I
called Ava and I was uh I was just
hell-bent on this idea that there were
people in donut stores all around the
world you know trying to charm their way
into getting free donuts and what did
what did Ava say to that she was she was
so patient and listening and you know
and then she was saying you know I I
think you might have you know drain
Babbage no notice there's doughnut
charmers everywhere and it's a problem
and and no one's doing anything about it
if this really happened yeah and she was
like I've been saying you have drain
damage as a joke but I think you might
have brain damage you know you should go
to the hospital did you go to the
hospital yes you did yeah and what they
say that I had a minor concussion
that explains it that's the only way to
explain this defense and all of that is
to say I don't really care what actors
think generally speaking it doesn't
really matter to me that if Ryan Gosling
thinks that this wasn't an American
achievement who cares what matters is
that the movie lies about history
revises history and it says this wasn't
an American achievement this is a human
achievement and Jeremy boring the
god-king and you know the sports
correspondent from our sister network
daily wire - he wrote a great piece
about this over the weekend where he
explained that sure it's a human
achievement America is the human
achievement all of the great
achievements of the last 200 years have
come from the United States they've come
from the United States because the
United States itself is a magnificent
human achievement an achievement of
freedom of the of the body politic of
the way that free markets and free ideas
and free thought and the anglo-american
inheritance of free politics has allowed
unbelievable developments in science
even art even the art that Ryan Gosling
is allowed to take part in that that's
certainly true it's a human achievement
but it's a human achievement done by
particular humans in a particular time
by a particular
that's America they want to wash over
that but when you abstract to beyond
what actually happened when you try to
create this generic abstraction you lose
all of the things that actually happened
and the issue here is the audience
because actors I say this I've acted
before that you know in indie movies and
plays and things like that I say this in
all humility actress aren't often not
the brightest people in the world
my old acting teacher one of the great
acting teachers he's been around for 70
years probably at this point teaching he
would say that actors have to become
gullible fools you have to become a
gullible fool that's not a knock on
actors it's because you need to be so
receptive to imaginary circumstances and
live truthfully and imaginary
circumstances so we don't expect our
actors to be able to you know lecture on
aspects of history or philosophy or
whatever the classic image you have is
of the sort of dumb actor there were
plenty of smart actors by the way I know
a lot of them out here I won't name them
oh there that James Woods is so out
there on Twitter I'll say he's very
smart I mean you went to MIT I think I
won't name the other smart actors I know
because they'll probably lose their
careers by virtue of having any
association with me but but James Woods
has already lost his agents that's fine
but but the trouble here is the audience
because about half the country is gonna
eat this up about half the country
believes where Ryan Gosling is saying
right now and look fortunately probably
half the country doesn't believe that
which is why I can't imagine this movie
is going to do very well it's it's
certainly not going to hit its
expectations there gonna be a lot of
people so turned off by this that gogo
broke is almost certainly going to
affect them as well but even then what
if their thought is because one of the
explanations for this is that they want
to be able to sell it overseas they
don't want to offend the foreign markets
by making this about planting an
American flag and so they're not gonna
put it in there that is a good argument
for nationalism if we are so dislodged
from our bonds of loyalty to our own
country this wonderful country of ours
is the greatest country in the history
of the world the most prosperous the
most generous the most charitable
country in the history of the world if
we're so divorced from our bonds of
loyalty to that country because we want
to make a buck in China that is a good
argument for national
that's actually an argument against
unfettered free trade that is I mean
there is something really that's lost by
this we're gonna be talking to the
political philosopher Yoram hezonia week
about his new book the virtues of
nationalism but that's this is a good
good argument for that we saw this in
2006 with that Superman movie when they
replaced truth justice in the American
way with truth justice and all that
other stuff so that's so horribly
offensive but it's going to affect this
movie mark my words if go get woke go
broke this has happened for every
company that's touched it Facebook and
Twitter for the first time ever this
year Facebook saw a decline in its daily
usership for the first time Twitter saw
a massive decline in its monthly user
ship why is that all of those numbers
coincided with the mass censorship and
ad integration of conservatives
suppression of conservative ideas on
those platforms when you start picking
aside when you start alienating half of
the country you're going to lose money
that's no coincidence same thing
happened with the NFL happen with a lot
of other people before I before we list
all of the examples of getting woke and
going broke I'll tell you how to not go
broke in this this age of ours and that
is by developing your skills on
Skillshare you know how much I love
Skillshare it's the online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing illustration data science
mobile photography creative writing you
name it they've got it these are
terrific classes when you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set start
a side hustle or just explore a new
passion skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving this is the advice
that especially people who are young or
just entering the job market who are
about to enter sometimes people ask they
say how do you get into doing what
you're doing and I say the key is not
writing a book but if you're not like me
if you can't not write a book and get
into it you need to have a lot of skills
because you you just need to be able to
supply what the employer is demanding
and that isn't just some major in
college I use this thing a lot you
should use it too I especially I don't
really care about technology that much
so when I want to hone up on that
I go to Skillshare Skillshare has
excellent classes on this you can access
it right away
and don't say I never did nothing for
you you can get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents this is a special
offer just for my listeners two months
for 99 cents Skillshare is offering me
michael knowles show listeners two
months of unlimited access to all of it
for just 99 cents so what you can do if
you're a real cheapskate you pay the 99
cents and then you take all twenty
thousand classes and then you're done
you don't have to do any more but you're
one gonna want to keep going sign up go
to Skillshare comp slash michael mi CH
AE L go to Skillshare dot-com / michael
mi CH AE l start you two months now
Skillshare dot-com / michael other
places that have learned to get woke go
broke or the NFL the NFL's ratings were
down 8% in 2016 in 2017 they were down
an additional 10% I wonder why gee I
wonder why this corresponds exactly to
the timing of the Colin Kaepernick
protest and Nike apparently saw that and
they said wow the NFL has managed to
turn off virtually all of their audience
by promoting this guy now we should get
him to be our spokesman that oh that's a
great we're making too much money we got
to start hemorrhaging money how about
the Oscars when the Oscars became this
political left-wing gab fest there last
year the Oscars ratings were down 19%
they were down 19% over the previous
year which was a nine-year low
how about CNN's ratings good is anybody
watching CNN no CNN is down 25% now
year-over-year in primetime and you got
to remember they're on in every Airport
in the world if you took out the
airport's I think they would have
negative ratings I don't know how that
works technically but I think there
would be fewer than zero people watching
them eat this even affects Marvel comic
books DC finally overtook Marvel comic
books in sales this was largely
attributed by analysts to Marvel taking
a turn for the social justice warriors
this is a really bad idea and it has a
lot to do with our politics as well we
can learn a lot when they're these
lefties are gonna be telling you look at
the polls it's awful for Republicans
don't stay just stay home Republicans
you're gonna lose it Trump's bad it's
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah look at the
real polls which are all of those
numbers because those polls are very
reactive they're very reactive to
markets and to real people it's still
socially unacceptable in many
orders to say that you support Donald
Trump it's acceptable and unacceptable
in many workplaces certainly on the
campuses in a lot of aspects of our
society so people are just not going to
say it but I'm telling you this guy has
not lost folks he's only gained votes
and you're seeing this reflected in
markets and you're seeing it in our
politics so today we had a really
hearing for Brett Kavanaugh to be
confirmed to the Supreme Court look at
how the Democrats behave themselves
here's Chuck Grassley the Republican
trying to hold these confirmation
hearings good morning I welcome everyone
to this confirmation hearing on the
nomination of mr. Brett Kavanaugh mr.
chairman to serve as associate justice
mr. Chairman I before we proceed mr.
chairman I'd like to be recognized to
ask a question before we proceed the
committee received just last night less
than 15 hours ago 4,000 pages of
documents that we have not had an
opportunity to review or read or analyze
you are you're out of order I'll proceed
we cannot possibly move forward mr.
chairman
there's two daughters mr. chairman or
Harris mr. chairman even doors were
closed and documents that we have and
everyone else join me tonight and we
believe this hearing should know this an
exciting day for all of you here and
you're rightly proud of them and if we
cannot be recognized I move to adjourn
the American people Chairman I move to
adjourn directly
mr. Chairman I move to adjourn
and mr. chairman petulant little
children chuck grassley handed him
handled himself so well here by not even
acknowledging their childish outbursts
their their neuralgic little outbursts
here it's it's it says a lot about this
party
they have no political recourse to this
nomination because the American people
voted them out resoundingly in large
part because of these Supreme Court
seats and they have nothing to offer
they have no points to say and so
they're going to interrupt they have no
respect for rules they have no respect
for decorum and they're just gonna say
but I don't like it I'm gonna don't use
it listen you have to conduct yourself
like an adult if you're not gonna
conduct yourself like an adult you're
going to be ignored all of them mr.
Chairman I move to adjourn well all
right you can move move whatever you
want go move right on out of this place
man because we're gonna confirm Brett
Kavanaugh hah hah hah hah hah they've
got nothing and this is what they're
gonna run on I mean the reason they did
this today is because they want to get
good footage for their TV commercials in
when they're in their own elections and
Kamala Harris who started all of that
off wants to get good footage for her
presidential commercials this is not
going to play well this doesn't look
good people don't really like this they
don't it's sort of like the psychology
of lines you know people don't mind it
how long a line is until people start
breaking the rules and then everybody
gets very anxious it's the same thing
with politics people don't mind when
they're out of power as long as they as
everyone's playing by the rules because
they know there's a way for them to get
back in power but when they start
breaking the rules like this when they
start trying to undercut the rules
shouting over people having no sense of
decorum it's chaos people hate that
people on the left and the right will
hate that voters will not like that so
good I hope you air this all over
television I hope you got your clips
today guys because it really doesn't
look good speaking of being petulant
little children Steve Bannon was invited
to headline the New Yorker conference
you know that magazine that nobody's
read for 30 years the one with the
cartoons that nobody understands the the
cartoons that are just dry to the point
of not being a joke so he was invited to
headline this conference and then there
was this massive
pushback by Judd Apatow and Patton
Oswalt's you know the great minds of our
generation Judd Apatow and Patton Oswalt
they they both said we're gonna pull out
of this if Steve Bannon is invited to
come and you know I'm gonna pull out of
it too I wasn't invited but I'm gonna
pull out of it too and they're gonna
pull out like petulant children I think
when finally the editor of The New
Yorker said okay we're gonna disinvite
him now okay and then they all said oh
good and they said I'm so relieved I'm
so relieved and of course they're
relieved
heaven forfend you hear a political
opinion that you disagree with
heaven forfend because what they're
saying about Steve Bannon is that he's a
Nazi and well I don't know Steve Bannon
I've never met Steve Bannon some of my
friends really don't like Steve Bannon
I'm more than willing to take their word
for it on him his interpersonal
relationships the guy's not a Nazi
there's no evidence that he's a Nazi
there's no evidence of that but they
just throw that around and they call
Steve Bannon a Nazi and they call
everybody else a Nazi they call Ben a
Nazi
they call him an Orthodox Jewish Nazi
they banded us about as look Steve
Bannon there are there many criticisms
that one can make of Steve Bannon like
for instance how he lost us a Republican
seat in Alabama how do you do that but
this guy is very important he was very
important in the 2016 election he was a
chief adviser of the President this guy
could shed a lot of light on this moment
in politics he is a perfect guest to
headline a conference that's about ideas
but they don't care about ideas they
want to they want to shut out any idea
that they disagree with they would be
horrified they'll start shaking and
crying if they hear an idea that they
disagree with Malcolm Gladwell the guy
who wrote those books like blink it was
the other outliers he wrote these very
popular books he eat tweeted about this
he said quote huh call me old-fashioned
but I would have thought that the point
of a festival of ideas was to expose the
audience to ideas if you only invite
your friends over it's called a dinner
party this is a very good point and
they're all everyone is coming in there
they're now piling on Malcolm Gladwell
this is a good point it's okay
ideas that you disagree with won't hurt
you by the way even they say well this
is racism and that's different it's it's
actually not really different you should
you should read ideas that are that bad
you should read ideas that are that you
really really disagree
that you really really really disagree
with it's important to do that the only
reason that you wouldn't expose yourself
to those ideas is because you're not
confident in your own ideas because
you're afraid that you'll become a Nazi
if you read on a book by a Nazi know if
you're if you're confident in your own
ideas and you'll see why the Nazi was
wrong and it will shed light on how the
Nazi thinks but they don't care about
any of that Chelsea Clinton tweeted IG
said quote for anyone who wonders what
normalization of bigotry looks like
please look no further than Steve Bannon
being invited by The Economist in The
New Yorker to their respective events in
New York a few weeks apart Chelsea
Clinton daughter of Bill Clinton who
recently sat on stage on a dais at a
wreath of Franklin's funeral with Louis
Farrakhan who regularly talks about how
we've got to get rid of all those
Satanic Jews who regularly in Vaes
against the Jews the head of the Nation
of Islam what about that bigotry she
didn't tweet about that when her father
was doing that did she talk about hate
they talk about hate hate hate the
Democrats are always projecting and so
they're always projecting their own
feelings onto someone else they're
saying Bannon is hateful he's hateful
and that's why we got to get them out
and you can't speak anywhere you say
who's the hateful one here who's the
hateful one seems like in there a little
irony here it seems like you might be
the hateful one here but it's that
politics that is so so despicable it's
so disgusting people don't like it there
are a lot of people who legitimately are
liberals who were on the Left who have
voted for a lot of Democrats who won't
vote for it now who won't vote for
Democrats now because they don't like
them we don't like this chaos we like a
little bit of order we like a little bit
of reason we like facts and facts don't
care about your feelings I mean that
this is true of liberals too and those
are the polls that matter I mean these
are the these are the things that matter
in this election
we're told Trump is never ever gonna win
he can't win Republicans are getting
totally blown out though we're gonna
they're gonna lose the Senate look at
look at the polls that matter though
look at what the left is doing what
votes have the Republicans lost what
votes did they have in 2016 that they've
lost in 2018 I don't see a whole lot and
and the news keeps getting better we've
got to go pretty soon but the news just
keeps getting better right now
another news report out today
Manufacturing Index is at a 14-year high
it's a 14-year high we've got
illegal aliens are getting off of
welfare and huge numbers that it's down
20% in certain states 600,000 people off
of the Dole because of President Trump
actually enforcing immigration well
things are going very well and the
economy is going very well
consumer confidence I don't know you're
high at an all-time high and
manufacturing this 14-year high this is
really good stuff 14 18 year highs
really good stuff and it's what really
makes me not believe the polls and it's
what really makes me not believe the new
book by Bob Woodward there's a new book
out by Bob board border which is saying
that all of trumps staff says he's crazy
and he's an idiot and he's a lunatic
and he doesn't know what he's doing and
it's just chaos at the White House it
okay I'm I kind of like Bob Woodward
he's a good journalist but what am I
gonna believe am I gonna believe what I
see happening in the country in the
world around me or am I gonna read the
gossip from X staffers that talk to Bob
Woodward what am I gonna believe because
all I know is that manufacturing is at a
14-year high consumer confidence 18-year
high unemployment is that in some in
some sectors all-time lows as stock
markets at all-time highs what am I
supposed to conclude from that if chaos
is what leads to that bring on the chaos
if crazy tweets is what leads to that
bring on the crazy tweets bring it on
man because I will all love the gossip
and Ivanka said this and John Kelly said
this and he said okay who cares I don't
care about any of that I care about
what's happening in the country in the
world and what's happening is very good
stuff and I that's what the American
people care about
that's why poll after poll show they
don't care about the rush investigation
they don't care about but Bob Muller
they don't care they care about what's
happening in their country economically
politically and culturally but they care
about what's happening in their country
that they can see and and what we're
seeing is good stuff so we've got to get
to what this means for the elections we
got to decrepit old Democrats who are
declaring or all but declaring that
they're gonna run for office before we
do that I gotta say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube I'm sorry I don't want to do
it but I have to we still have a lot to
get to I want to talk about John
McCain's funeral politicians
politicizing the funeral I also want to
explain Sarah Silverman's joke to her
because she doesn't seem to understand
it she tweeted at me that she doesn't
she doesn't seem to understand it so
I'll explain it to her
before all that though you're gonna want
get the leftist here's tumblr before
Nikes stock falls even more because then
you're not gonna be able to contain it
you're not gonna be able to swim to
safety if you don't have the leftist
here's tumblr to contain all of that so
go to daily wire.com right now get the
Colin Kapernick edition believe in
something even if it means drinking all
the leftist tears believe and just do it
just go to daily wire come just do it
we'll be right back
so what does this mean for politics we
see the left imploding we see companies
that embrace the left imploding we see
all of the economic and political
indicators in the country going up and
up and up and up and up for Republicans
so what does this mean it means and I
don't want to say I don't want to jinx
this by even saying it out loud it means
that in 2020 the the Democrat nominee
might be it might be John Kerry if my
okay I'll say it I hope I didn't just
jinx it for comment because John Kerry
has suggested as much as he might run
for comment we turn now to former
Secretary of State John Kerry news and
dream that's well I hope if he's elected
president that he'll just news and
dreamin dreamin snooze there is John
Kerry Howell the third uh monkey Teresa
really bring me Masha bleah really John
Kerry might actually run for president
he was asked about this in an interview
and he said well well well monkey I'm
not thinking about 2020 right now I'm
just thinking about electing people in
2018 which is what people say when
they're running in 2020 it does seem
he's very interested in he said before
that he got close enough that he should
run again he didn't get close enough by
the way Georgia W Bush decisively won
its election against John Kerry but that
is neither here nor there
if only he runs President Trump says the
same thing he tweeted up oh I should
only be so lucky to run against John
Kerry John Kerry is the most out of
touch candidate second only perhaps to
the other woman who is now certainly
going to run for president Elizabeth
alaya wathah Warren Elizabeth Warren the
way we know that she's running for
president now is she's sending out this
PR blitz in just the last week you might
have seen this the the Boston Globe ran
a headline quote ethnicity not a factor
in Elizabeth Warren's rise in law first
of all why is that news second of all
that isn't true we know that it was
because she put it on her application
and we know that a native of
Americans have an advantage in hiring
they have an ethnic advantage in hiring
because of affirmative action policies
so that just isn't true other stories
have been planted - it wasn't a factor
it wasn't a factor but it was a factor
and this this woman is so unlikable
she's so shrill and unlikable but the
reason that that's gonna dog her the
reason I think that's a fatal blow to
her candidacy for president is it it
just shows how utterly inauthentic she
is it shows what a total fraud she is
when you look at Liz Warren she is the
whitest woman to ever walk the face of
the earth she is she is whiter than
Thurston Howell the third John Kerry I
mean she is so and she cynically played
on affirmative action and she's
cynically playing on policies that she
supports so there's even the fraud and
the inauthenticity of the support for
those policies because she gained the
system to get an advantage the minute
she could you know it's all words words
words talk talk talk with her and it's
so divorced from reality so I I mean if
those are the two candidates I hope so
if we get Kamala Harris great you know
just shouting down like a deranged
maniac shouting down chuck Grassley in
what's supposed to be an orderly Senate
hearing I hope so cory booker can't
control any of his emotions cory booker
tears of rage totally off the deep end
this is why you'll you'll hear the left
and the anti-trump right they'll say but
the generic ballot we're really down on
the generic ballot there is no generic
candidate
there's no generic race for president
the closest we came was Mitt Romney and
they even managed to turn him into some
monstrous vicious dog abusing gay boy
hair cutting criminal I don't know there
is no generic candidate it's only people
you only run against people sometimes
the anti-trump right we'll say well
Trump didn't win the election Hillary
lost the election sure Hillary Hillary
lost and therefore Trump won and Trump
won and therefore Hillary lost you run
against real people you don't
presidential elections are not
abstractions they're not a theory they
happen in real time with real people so
the question is right now and look the
the 2020 nominee for the Democrats could
be someone that we haven't heard from
yet probably will be someone we haven't
heard from yet but if it's the people we
have heard from
who's gonna beat Donald Trump John Kerry
is John Kerry and Theresa and I really
want to beat Donnie I have to beat him
on down in the polls RiRi is he really
gonna be Donald Trump how about Joe
Biden this guy is creepy guy who's on
video and undeniably on video is
creeping on all these young girls
smelling their hair is that guy gonna do
it a guy who was run out of the
presidential race thirty years ago
because he's a plagiarist is that guy
gonna beat him Joe Biden is with the
least sincere person in America he plays
an author and authentic guy on TV but he
isn't one is that guy really gonna win a
contest of authenticity with Donald
Trump about Kamala Harris is she gonna
beat him
I bet Liz Warren Lyle Wafaa Foca hunt is
is she gonna beat him who's gonna bat
cory booker weeping tears of rage as
donald trump gobbles up his leftist ears
is he gonna who's gonna beat him where
is he then these are all put particular
races nothing is generic if we were in
generic times we wouldn't have donald
trump as the president we're in real
particular times I've got to go pretty
soon so I do want to say a few words
about John McCain's funeral because that
was wall-to-wall coverage for the last
few days the the issue with this funeral
I'll give some personal thoughts on this
the issue is in 20 years
everyone's gonna feel foolish about this
funeral that's the really sad part
because John McCain had made great
sacrifices he served his country and his
funeral was made small by politicians
here is Barack Obama using John McCain's
funeral to swipe at Trump John believed
in honest argument and hearing other
views he understood that if we get in
the habit of bending of the truth to
suit political expediency or party
orthodoxy our democracy will not work
that's why I was willing to buck his own
party at times occasionally work across
the aisle on campaign finance reform and
immigration reform that's why he
championed a free and independent press
as vital to our democratic debate and
the fact that it
some good coverage didn't hurt either
you see look at what he is focusing on
immigration reform the press
CBC that's why McCain is good because he
didn't want to enforce immigration law
and he wanted to change immigration law
to allow more people to come in and to
give amnesty to illegal aliens here and
because he was really he really liked
the press notice that he's using all of
these swipes at Donald Trump the reason
John McCain was good to Barack Obama is
because he would go against his own
party you know the Republican Party that
wicked party that's an office right now
and he actually kind of shows his hand
which is that it got him good headlines
that is true it did get him good
headlines by the press which is the
communications wing of the Democrat
Party and Barack Obama goes on John
understood as JFK understood as Ronald
Reagan understood that part of what
makes our country great is that our
membership is based not on our bloodline
not on what we look like what our last
name sorry it's not based on where our
parents or grandparents came from or how
recently they arrived but on adherence
to a common creed or how recently they
arrived hmm
looking at you Donald mmm it's so
shallow and now I I want to play Megan
McCain's clip because it is being played
all over the world this was the defining
moment of the funeral I don't I give
Megan McCain a pass because her father
died so I'll preface it with that but I
do want to talk about what she said
because people can learn some lessons
from it here's megan mccain we gather
here to mourn the passing of american
greatness the real thing not cheap
rhetoric from men who will never come
near the sacrifice he gave so willingly
nor the opportunistic appropriation of
those who live lives of comfort and
privilege while he suffered and served
the america of john mccain is generous
and welcoming and bold she is
resourceful and con's
secur she meets her responsibilities
she speaks quietly because she is strong
America does not both because she has no
need to the America of John McCain has
no need to be made great again because
America was always great there is the
line there is the line this whole final
in vain against Donald Trump the the
reason this was a bad idea and again I
give Megan a pass because her father
died but I speak a little bit from
experience having eulogized to parent
myself the feelings in that moment are
so intense the apparent crisis the
urgency the shock even you know and
obviously people knew that John McCain
was was going to die but that when it
actually happens the the shock is so
intense that it distorts your
perspective and it distorts your
perspective of the significance of the
moment and the importance of outside
circumstances to the moment and and all
of those things and you really have to
be careful because you you don't want to
let the the craziness of the moment the
shock they hurt the pain of the moment
caused you to say things that are a
little off tone because John McCain's
life is bigger than one presidency I
hope it's bigger than one presidency
I hope John McCain's life doesn't just
boil down to a guy who was elected
president in 2016
I think it has more to it than that but
by politicizing this funeral it it
shrinks the life of John McCain and it
politicizes it into a moment that won't
really matter because the fact is we
were told time and again that if Donald
Trump were elected the sky would fall
and it didn't fall he's been a good
president the country has thrived under
his leadership will it be a historic
presidency perhaps it will or perhaps it
won't be perhaps there'll be a bigger
presidency that comes afterward and the
circumstances of the daily politics are
not going to matter when we think about
the life of John McCain but when we look
back at the funeral of John McCain it's
going to be all about Trump
that's a very strange thing I say this
with great compassion for Megan McCain I
know what it feels like but I think we
can all take something from that which
is that this this guy is alive John
McCain's life is bigger than a than the
president than the current president
it's bigger than that it should be
bigger than that and we should remember
him for things that don't have to do
with daily politics before we go I just
have to make fun of serif Silverman
Sarah Silverman I've been tweeting with
her all morning because she doesn't
understand her own joke here is Sarah
Silverman's promo for her show I Love
You America I will send you to hell for
eternity if you murder steal do
guy-on-guy but sex
what what that's true
you really put people in hell for
eternity if they put their penis in an
anus mm-hmm
are you serious I cannot believe Sarah
take a chill pill I'm kidding
I created gay people Oh whew ah you got
me you're a real son of a gun god call
me oh okay oh Allah
well well well hey everyone frantically
typing emails about how I'm once again
disrespecting the Christian God guess
what mother
so I tweeted to Sarah Silverman I said
wow that was really funny
now do it for Muslims now do that joke
for Muslims and she responded sarah said
ha you didn't watch the clip because at
the end I'm really talking to Allah
ha ha ha ha ha is it right right so I'd
like to explain Sarah Silverman's joke
to her there were two parts of this joke
the first part opens up and you're
talking to God you're not talking to
Holly you're talking to God hey God and
you're right and you're you're talking
about the moral law and he says don't
kill don't steal and don't commit sodomy
and you say what that's crazy and then
he's like yeah I was just kidding about
that one ha ha right so that's the first
joke that's a joke about Christianity
then it turns at the end and he says and
my name is Allah right and the second
part of that joke is a joke that
ostensibly you were always making a joke
about the Muslim God and therefore the
Christian mother effers who are
frantically typing emails should stuff
it that's there are two jokes one is
about the moral law to God that you're
talking to and the second part is a joke
the object of which is the Christian
people who are offended by your first
joke and you say ha ha joke's on you
mother effers I was really talking about
the God of Islam but you weren't really
talking about the God of Islam that's
the that's the turn of the joke ok so
the object of that joke are Christians
right my challenge to Sarah Silverman is
now do a joke were the object of
ridicule as Muslims do that one the guys
that Charlie Hebdo did that Danish
cartoonists did that and they paid what
they paid with their lives so you won't
do that will you
and as she actually responded she
admitted this she said yes you're right
the the object of ridicule here is the
Christians and the reason I'm doing that
is because America is a Christian
country is mostly Christian and so I
punch up I don't punch down Christians
are the most persecuted religious group
in the entire world this is not don't
take my word for it the study and study
from various centers including Pew
Research and University of Notre Dame
have shown this it's the most persecuted
religious group in the world they're
beheaded in Libya they are crucified in
Syria they are mutilated in Indonesia
they are the most persecuted religious
group in the world most of that
persecution a lot of that persecution
comes at the hands of Muslim terrorists
so what is punching up really mean
what is punching let's see if she has
the guts to do a joke the object of
which is Muslims I don't think she will
which is why it's why our typical boring
comedy does she know that Michelle wolf
got canceled by the way did someone
someone should tell her before Sarah
Silverman gets a rude awakening okay
that's our show for today we got a lot
more coming up so be sure to tune back
in tomorrow because the this man that
long weekend really messes you up you
got there's too much to cover plus we're
gonna have some good guests coming up
too so in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy bori senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua ov era the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018